I just watched the film and my goodness
you guys are absolutely amazing in this
film I love you both so much and you
guys both have this capability of
telling such a big story in the quietest
moments so congratulations to the both
of you uh the reviews are amazing as
well potential Oscar winners what does
that feel like the people that are just
loving it so much
do you know what this this film has been
a passion project for us just now I've
been attached to it for six years to be
a slim home our director is a director
that we both admire this is his first
English language film and I feel so
proud to be telling what I think is Amy
lochran's story the character that just
plays a really really important story
and I'm so thrilled that people are
reacting to it so thank you yeah I mean
there's that scene with you Eddie uh how
does how does an actor get into the
mindset of like a very unique serial
killer this is a story that I've never
heard of before
um do you know I hadn't heard of it
either but there is a really brilliant
book called the goodness which this film
is sort of the last third of and the
other two-thirds are
biography of Charlie and really intimate
detail of his upbringing and his trauma
and some of this horrific behavior that
he'd done so it was kind of like an
actor's dream to have that as a Bible
um so that that was my insight and then
the real Amy that Jess and I were lucky
enough to spend time with she her major
thing for us was talking about the truth
of that love and friendship between
these two people that that Charlie
Cullen was two different people he was a
very good friend that saved her life and
a Monster who was doing unspeakable
things
Jessica did Amy say anything that kind
of helped you with bringing her
character to life
yeah I mean I had read of course the
book The good nurse
um I we went to nursing school I did I
learned everything I could about the
information and you know the technical
aspects of it and then talking to her
over Zoom because it was during the
pandemic
um before we started filming we had an
opportunity to meet over Zoom she said
something to me that really opened up
the character in a way that I hadn't
imagined I asked her why did you work as
a Night Nurse like why because it's such
a difficult thing to do why not work you
know and she said I wanted my children
to think that they had a stay-at-home
mom
and I was so moved by that this idea of
this woman who was struggling with
cardiomyopathy she needed a heart
transplant she's working all night long
taking care of others she comes home and
she sleeps for a few hours when our kids
are at school and then she's awake she's
not and taking care of her kids she's
not really taking care of herself in any
of that situation and for me that was my
way in to this this person
now code purple is the pizza has a react
so what's what's your favorite type of
pizza please tell me you like pineapple
ew not that nice that is horrific I
couldn't agree more I couldn't agree
holy Moses but that night we've been
shooting a really late night shoot we
were both Jess to get her heart beat up
was doing these Marathon runs around the
set in order to play never has pizza
been more appreciated we just kept
talking about it too they're like it's
the pizza scene what are you sure you
want I was like yes I want pizza they're
like what kind would you like I think
mine I think was just like a simple
cheese pizza maybe with some basil and
some tomato I love a lot of sauce my hot
meat Feast bit of everything I think I
was like I love pizza but but Pizza when
you're really hungry oh my gosh
and also in the morning yeah uh Heaven
dipped it I mean it has to be vegan
ranch dressing but ranch dressing cold
pizza and ranch dressing I'm there for
it yeah but try pineapple you made them
nice I tried pineapple we've all been
children at some points in a pineapple
pizza
we've moved on
my husband would murder me if I was
eating pineapple pizza yeah he's an
Italian
yeah well if you win an Oscar make sure
you have a pineapple pizza a Hawaii
Pizza okay thank you so much to both of
you take care thanks everybody bye